retour en Bourgogne pour la suite de
cette soirée spéciale élection
départementale sur France 3 avec des
résultats et des invités avec nous nous
ont rejoint Ludovic Rochette bonsoir
viceprésident UMP du conseil général et
candidats sur le canton de Dijon 4 et
puis Christian lonet président du groupe
FN au conseil régional bonsoir à vous
candidat également sur le canton de
Blanz séine Maglica pour le Parti
socialiste nous rejoint dans les minutes
à venir les résultats d'abord avec en
préfecture de Macon Damien boutiller
résultats sur le canton de louand
Damien exactement un canton très attendu
celui du président du conseil général
sortant Rémy chintron et de sa
colissière Sabine Cheffer qui se font
distancer
30,80 % et c'est l'UMP Mathilde
chalumeau Anthony vado qui arrive en
tête avec
48,48 % soit
1473 voix d'écart et puis dans la série
des triangulaires je vous en donnis
trois tout à l'heure il y en a deux
autres une 4è c'est parti pour Pierre de
Bresse où c'est Aline Gruet avec ave son
colissier
35,74 % suivi par la gauche 32,40 % et
Sébastien loin du front national
31,86 %. autre triangulaire Cuiseau
c'est la gauche qui arrive en tête
Frédéric canard conseiller général
sortant avec son binôme
35,79 % suivi du binôme de droit 34,20
et puis le Front National qui s'accroche
à
30,01 %. et puis à givre un duel droite
extrême droite en prévision Sébastien
Martin et Dominique lanoiselé arrivve en
tête avec
45,74 % talonné par le Front national
21,23 %. autre résultat au creusau 2 où
cette fois c'est le Front National qui
sera face au PS le PS arrive en tête
40,75 % pour Eveline couillot et son
colistier quant au Front national
23,36 %. autre résultat à Digouin cette
fois c'est un duel entre Fabien Jeunet
avec edit podin face à philomè Bacco et
Jean-Paul drapier
41,18 pour la droite
27,96 pour la gauche et puis pour finir
monsouéine duel classique gauche droite
35,29 % pour les candidats de droite
suivi par la gauche à
29,66 % voici pour les résultats merci
Damien Eric SIO sur ce département de la
Sonel ou bien moutiller nous parler au
tout début du score du président sortant
Rémy chintron qui fait un score très bas
30,8 % contre le candidat UMP 48,48 %
c'est un peu le symbole de ce
département qui est 1ès enfin la gauche
est très en difficulté dans ce
département il y a au moins quatre
cantons qui pourraient basculer d'après
ce qu'on voit pour l'instant Louan
Digouin ha 1 Macon 2 Macon 1 pardon et
de nombreuses triangulaires qui restent
très incertaines et on se posait des
questions aussi sur les cantons
bressants parce qu'il faut se souvenir
que lorsque le Conseil Général de Colard
avait basculé ça avait beaucoup été sous
l'impulsion d'Arnaud monondbourg et
qu'un certain nombre de cantons de Bress
étaent tombé un petit peu comme des
dominos qui avait entraîné la chute de
la majorité de René bomon à l'époque on
regardait précisément résultat de
Frédéric canard dans le canton de
Cuiseau parce qu'il avait été le symbole
dans le symbole Frédéric canard parce
qu'il avait battu à l'époque rené
Beaumont il y a une triangulaire et un
résultat finalement peut-être moins
difficile que ce que l'on pensait parce
qu'il faut se dire aussi que des des
cantons ont été impactés par le
redécoupage et quand le concurrence
frééric canard c'est quelqu'un qui est
très impacté par le redécoupage et dans
une situation beaucoup plus difficile
qu'il ne l'était précédemment et on peut
noter que c'est l'un des départements il
a finalement le moins de duel avec le
Front national contrairement à Lyonne on
en reparlera mais on peut d'ors et déjà
l'annoncer pour la suite de cette
tranche où il y a beaucoup de duels avec
le Front national pour le deuxème tour
et nous partons justement pour Lyon
Nathalie baffire nous attend préfecture
d'osser Nathalie pour de nouveaux
résultats absolument et je commence par
ce premier élu dans Lyonne dans le
canton du Nord nord de Lyonne le gaâtiné
en Bourgogne le l'UMP Jean-Baptiste Le
mooine est élu dès le premier tour avec
59,2 % Jean-Baptiste ruman associé à
Delphine gréy un résultat résultat
attendu puisqu'il n'y avait que deux
candidats UMP face au FN il est donc élu
dès le premier tour sur le canton d'ser
2 ce sera un duel entre l'UMP et le
Front
national Robert Bidau associal Malie
counais donc obtiennent 36,72 % et ils
seront donc face à Julien Gubert et
Sylvian bourgeois Julien liber vous en
rappelez c'était le candidat qui avait
raté d'un cheveux le second tour des
municipales àoser l'an dernier à oser 3
c'est l'UMP qui est en tête avec
Christophe Bonnefond is Isabelle
joakina qui seront là ce sera un duel
face au Parti socialiste swad Aami
Daniel lubranevski obtienent
27,51 % duel donc UMP PS sur oser 3
Brinon sur
armençon c'est donc là le front national
une fois encore qui arrive en tête
36,04 % Claude daciier et Monique
Fernandez ils seront opposés un binôme
UMP jean-marchand Catherine MODET 30,49
%. à Sens sens 1 c'est Gilles piermand
Le sorton divivers droite qui n'a pas
donc eu l'investiture de l'UMP qui
obtient avec Daniel gicel 31,43 % et il
sera opposé au Front national l'encore
Raphaël proi Delm obtienent 25,84 % à
Avalon c'est l'UMP qui est en tête
Xavier courtois et Sonia patouret
obtiennent 30,39 % ce sera une
triangulaire là à valallon face donc au
Parti socialiste et au Front national
27,80 pour le le Parti socialiste et
28,31 pour le Front national enfin à
Villeneuve suron un duel Front national
PS le sortons le maire de PS 2009 Suran
Cyril boulot et Lilian lavoau abtien
27,1 % et c'est donc le Front National
qui est en tête ericaa rosé et Claude
Thion
35,02 duel donc FN PS à villene sur
Yonne merci Nathalie B faire depuis oser
FN fort dans Lyonne const ce soir FN un
FN fort dans Lyonne on en a beaucoup
parlé dans la première tranche et un FN
qui s'engouffre aussi dans les divisions
de la droite de Lyonne on l'avait dit
c'est un des enjeux de cette soirée
est-ce que entre l'UDI et l'UMP il y a
quand même alors même si elle est
souterraine une guerre pour reprendre ou
pas la présidence du conseil général il
y a un certain nombre de cantons avec
des candidats UD candidats um qui vont
être privés de deuxè tour sur la base de
cette division c'est le cas à Joigny
c'est le cas dans d'autres cantons aussi
et et la question va être aussi de
savoir si cette division va laisser des
traces dans dans certains cantons c'est
par exemple les cantons soutenus par le
président du conseil général André
Villier qui sont passés les autres ne
sont pas passés quel va être le niveau
on va dire de la rivalité et du soutien
ou pas ça c'est l'entre de Tours qui va
nous le dire et le et le deuxème tour et
on va ajouter que le le les forces de
gauche mais on s'y attendait sont très
très faibles dans Lyonne à l'exception à
osser à Joanie et à villeneu sur Lyonne
nous en débatttrons avec nos invités
bien évidemment direction never tout de
suite régise Guillon pour de nouveaux
résultats dans votre département
oui et je vous emmène dans le canton de
cnecour surloire où dimanche prochain il
y aura un duel droite extrême droite
Michel venau le maire de cône surloire
est arrivé en tête avec son binô bien
sûr en totalisant 36,45 % des voix et il
sera donc opposé à un binôme Front
National qui lui a réalisé
30,62 % des voix et puis un résultat
encore qui concerne ne vous savez que ne
a été découpé en quatre cantons nous
avons vu déjà trois cantons et bien
voici le dernier c'est 1
1 où là la gauche arrive en tête incarné
par le Conseiller Général sortant
Jean-Louis baleray avec
35,57 % des voix il sera donc au second
tour contre un binôme Nièvre à venir
vous savez c'est ce mouvement initié par
le maire de Neu qui avait lancé lui à
l'occasion des municipales ne à venir il
voulait réitérer et envoyer comme ça des
candidats venus d'un peu tous les coins
mais sans étiquette voilà venir défendre
cette bannière Nièvre à venir et bien
donc il y aura ce duel dimanche prochain
entre euh le PS pour faire simple et
Nièvre à venir et alors ce qui sera
intéressant de savoir aussi c'est que va
décider le maire de Never va-t-il
appeler à à voter pour des candidats de
gauche lorsqu'ils seront opposé au
candidats du Front national je pense par
exemple à 9r2 où là le FN est arrivé en
tête avec 16 voix d'avance par rapport à
la candidate et au binôme socialiste et
de gauche et à la candidate sortante
Delphine fleur voilà question à poser
mais je crois que Denis tuot et d'autres
invités viendront bientôt s'exprimer à
ma place ici en préfecture de Neu vous
êtes au courant merci beaucoup Régis
commentaire sur la Nièvre difficile pour
l'instant de faire des comptes précis
pour savoir si on est ou pas dans une
situation de bascule pour l'anniè
l'exemple par exemple du canton de de
cône cours surloire dont le PS va être
éliminé c'est quand même rare dans la
Nièvre il faut dire que c'est la
réunification de deux anciens cantons un
canton de droite un canton de gauche
alors de façon mathématique on peut dire
que là où il y avait un conseiller
général de droite un conseiller général
de gauche il y aura deux un binôme de
droite donc on voit un légerre avantage
qui est pris tout ça nous permet pas
pour l'instant de dire si la majorité
peut changer au conseil général dans le
Conseil Général de la donc
départementale de la Nièvre le point
intéressant c'est aussi ce qui se passe
sur la ville de neververre on est bien
dans la suite des élections municipales
avec ses candidats estampiés par le
maire de neververre mais aussi il faut
regarder précisément il y a un certain
nombre de cantons avec par exemple le
parti nouvelle donne qui existe assez
peu à l'échelle nationale et à l'échelle
régionale mais qui je crois sur un ou
deux cantons fait plusieurs points et et
donc ça va compter aussi la question
sera de savoir si c'est des gens qui
sont proches du parti socialiste ou si
c'est des gens qui souhaitent ne pas
apporter leur voix au Parti socialiste
au deème tour donc tout ça va compter
mais dans l'esprit des élections
municipales de Never la soirée continue
sur France 3 Bourgogne sur France 3.fr
nous partons pour 10jon pour de nouveaux
résultats en compagnie de Lise riget en
préfecture de Dijon
oui d'abord un résultat dans le canton
d'sonne avec un duel droite extrême
droite et notamment Dominique Girard et
MarieClaire valet qui passe donc en tête
à
19,08 % et puis en seconde donc le Front
national Johann Bassan et Marie Poussard
17,89 on en vient donc ensuite au canton
urbain au canton dijonnais là aussi avec
donc un tandem qui passe qui est élu
déjà dès ce premier tour à savoir et
bien le maire de Dijon Alain Millot et
sa première adjointe Nathalie kindenders
qui passe donc ça passe juste
25,42 % élection donc de ce binôme pour
le canton de Dijon 2 à gauche bien sûr
la gauche également en tête euh dans ce
premier tour dans le canton de Dijon 5
l'union de la gauche avec Christophe
AVENA et colollette popardin qui fait
partie de la garde rapprochée de
François
repsamen donc là on aura droit à une non
à un duo aussi
19,63 %. et l'Union de la Droite avec
Franck hayash et Amélia novoau ça ne
passe pas en revanche pour le Front
national sur ce canton de Dijon 5 en ce
qui concerne Dijon qure maintenant un
canton sur lequel la droite misait
beaucoup et bien là aussi c'est la
gauche qui est en tête avec le tandem
Océane Charet Godar adjointte au maire
de Dijon ainsi que Jean ifpan
1799 suivi de près par un duel de la
droite àerchen et Ludovic Rochette
ensuite on poursuit également avec cette
fois-ci Dijon 1 c'était Taki là aussi
presque pas complètement un score
relativement élevé cette fois-ci pour la
droite François Xavier dugour Daniel
Darfeuille
23,55 % pour ce premier tour c'est un
petit peu plus loin pour le tandem de
l'union de la gauche avec Jean-Philippe
consè et Catherine Hervieux et puis donc
pas de Front national non plus pour ce
canton de Dijon 1 et puis nous avons
également le canton de Longvie qui vient
de nous parvenir avec là une
triangulaire là aussi canton sur lequel
la gauche pouvait être en danger la
gauche qui est tout de même en tête
Christophe Lucan et Céline tonneau
16,68 suivi de l'Union de la Droite
Jean-Philippe Morel et Marie quintalet
et puis donc le Front national également
he pour cette triangulaire Véronique
Juliard David TREC
14,44 %. merci lise r depuis la
préfecture de cor je vois que l'on
regarde France 3 la seule chaîne à vous
proposer une soirée spéciale élection
départementale une précision concernant
le canton de Dijon 2 précer les chiffres
dijonet Dijon 2 VO alors on va commencer
par le canton urbain de Dijon 1 où la
droite est devant donc le tandem Daniel
Darfeuille François Xavier du courour
totalise 44 % des voix il devance le
tandem PS Europe Écologie Les vert 37 %
le canton de Dijon sacou la gauche est
en tête Christophe avena Colette Popard
28 % des voix devance slobino mudé
divers droite franc aay amélier améliia
pardonnez-moi novoau 24 % des voix Dijon
4 le PS en ballotage favorable les
socialistes 35 % devance l'UMP 32 % et
le Front national 21 %. enfin Dijon 2
duel gauche droite dans ce canton 2è
tour le maire de Dijon on l'a dit tout à
l'heure Alain Millot et sa première
adjointe naalie kund sont en tête avec
48 % des suffrages ils seront opposé au
2ème tour à Emmanuel Bichot UMP lor
Jaillet divers droite le tandem
recueille 31 % des voix il donc bien un
2ème tour sur ce cont de Dijon
2our Cline magilka qui nous a rejoint
bonsoir euh la gauche résiste bien sur
Dijon oui tout à fait c'est on n pas
votre résultats vous par contre alors je
crois que on est autour de 38 39 et que
on sera face au Front National au 2e
tour mais sur Dijon 6 mais effectivement
ce que l'on constate c'est que sur Dijon
les candidats résistent bien résistent
bien parce que un vrai travail de
proximité a été fait ce sont des élus de
terrain des élus qui ont montré leur
capacité justement à s'adresser aux
citoyens aux citoyennes je crois qu'il y
a un gros travail de terrain qui a été
réalisé un gros travail de proximité et
qu'on a su aussi parler dans ces cantons
du département ce qui n'a pas été le cas
partout de ses compétences et on a sur
rappeler les valeurs de solidarité de
fraternité et le Conseil départemental
puisque c'est comme ça qu'il va
s'appeler maintenant et bien ces
compétences est autour de l'action
sociale et ça touche la vie des gens au
quotidien et je crois que les candidats
dijunnais et de l'agglomération ont su
montrer qu'ils étaient capables de faire
ce travail Ludovique Rochette quand on
Dijon 4 c'est le vôtre euh vous êtes en
2e position après ce premier tour avec
180 voix de de retard sur le binôme de
gauche euh le Front national n'accède
pas au 2ème tour en gros il y a 1200
voies du Front national sur la table
quel est vot votre position à vous après
ce premier tour par rapport aux
électeurs qui ont fait le choix du Front
national dans cette élection il y a un
autre facteur aussi c'est l'abstention
parce qu' on est sur un électeur sur
deux qui s'est qui s'est déplacé
aujourd'hui et je pense déjà à eux à eux
qui doivent venir le 29 mars prochain
pour montrer qu' qu'ils vont nous faire
confiance àerchin et moi-même et puis
ben
concernant la campagne on a eu quand
même affaire à à des candidats fantôme
les candidats FN vousz à côté de vous
oui sur mon cantô je peux vous dire ce
sont des candidats fantômes et je veux
bien distinguer ce qui est du FN et de
leurs candidats et et et et l'électorat
parce que bien sûr que je pense que vous
vu aussi sur votre canton on a rencontré
de la colère on a rencontré des des
attentes et ce ce résultat là euh me
surprend pas beaucoup je suis d'ailleurs
très content moi de de ce résultat sur
le carton du Jan 4 parce qu'on situation
de de gagner ce con duj 4 alors que le
découpage au départ était pas fait dans
ce sens donc notre résultat est est
vraiment positif on peut peut-être poser
la question au au Front national bon on
a un représentant ici de de la sonéoire
mais vous pouvez nous parler quand même
de de de ces situations comme sur ce
canton là ou le il y a plus de candidats
FN qu'est-ce que vous dites aux
électeurs qui ont voté pour vous au
premier tour finalement
d'abord les candidats fantômes monsieur
ce sont d'abord des candidats du peuple
hein ce sont pas des apparat
ce sont des gens qui représentent le
peuple dans toutes ses composantes et
aussi toutes ces et qui porent des
plaintes que ni l'UMP ni le PS n'ont
pris en compte jusqu'à présent mais je
voudrais si vous me permettez en guise
de préliminaire dénoncer dénoncer le
terme d'extrême droite parce que c'est
une appellation qui me
paraît sinon sinon malveillante du moins
péjorative je rappelle que la préfecture
ne classe pas le Front national parmi
les formations d'extrême droite nous
sommes peut-être d'extrême d'extrême
droiture ou d'extrême fidélité
à à la France et et aux Français mais en
aucun cas nous ne sommes extrémistes ni
dans nos propos ni dans nos c'est origin
du Front national qui font que c'est un
parti d'extrême droite et oui oui
peut-être mais je je vous rappelle
qu'officiellement nous sommes Front
national droite nationale si vous voulez
ou social mais extrême et extrémiste non
certains candidats on quand même eu un
certain nombre de soucis on peut prendre
un candidat surtill en Côte d'Or on peut
prendre un candidat de Lyonne qui a fait
l'apologie de bréviic sur son sur sa
page Facebook quand même pardonnez-moi
mais et bien monsieur monsieur Mel ces
ces ces candidats seront seront
sanctionnés eu pas éé avantélection
parce qu'on ne peut pas
invalider une une candidature dans la
mesure où elle a été déposée en
préfecture on peut retirer une étiquette
investiture pe on peut retirer une une
étiquette ces personnes seront seront
seront sanctionné suspendu voir exclu
mais c'est pas tout à fait le cas c'est
pas tout à fait la pratique dans les
dans les partis qui nous gouvernent on
s'aperçoit par exemple que des personnes
qui sont régulièrement mises en justice
Jupé balcanie d'assaau et bien continue
de de de pavoiser et de et d'occuper des
places prééminentes y compris y compris
y compris au PS d'ailleurs entre
cambaliis Julien Dray Harlem Désir mais
sur le fond sur le fond je voudrais
quand même tout de même euh
et j'en termine et j'en termine non
c'est Monsieur mulet qui me parlait du
dérappage et j'en termine sur le fond
concernant concernant écoutez lorsque
Monsieur Cahusac ou monsieur tevenou euh
se mettent en délicatesse avec la la la
loi euh
c'est est-ce que pour autant on sait que
quand il y a une institution il y a des
hommes et quand il y a des hommes il y a
de l'hommerie est-ce que pour est-ce que
pour autant ça disqualifie le le Parti
socialiste et son programme moi je je
n'assimile pas euh les comportement des
des personnes avec avec le le le un
programme et je voudrais bien qu'onon
fasse qu'on en fasse de même pour nous
pour de la question d'origine pour le
deè par que c'était quand même ma
question à l'origine vous dit exemple du
canton de Ludovique Rochet frond
national n'ac pas deux tour écoutez le
le
le on appelle les partis au pouvoir
l'UMP ou le PS enfin l'UMP en
l'occurrence puisqu'il est en
concurrence avec le le PS appel au
changement mais en fait ça ne va pas
changer une élection d'unand d'un
conseiller départemental de plus ça ne
va pas changer grand-chose parce que les
deux formations qui sont apparemment
concurrentielles les deux formations
disposent du du même logiciel
fondamental ils sont tous les deux
européistes
ultraalibéraux
immigrationnistes donc en fait ils ont
clairement abandonné le le peuple et et
et et la nation donc concrètement je
pense
que conrtement concrètement on sa on
sait très bien que les consignes de vote
euh c'est c'est c'est sont pas toujours
suivis des faits qu'il faut que les
personnes votent en leur âme et
conscience mais dans mon cas dans mon
cas moi je m'abstiendrai au second tour
et ben ça été long mais on
l' de vous réag oui parce que la Côte
d'Or est bien loin là d'ailleurs aussi
loin dans les document de de de votre
parti parce que la cô d'or n citit
aucune fois dans vos documents et et là
ce soir on parle des départemental par
Monsieur Rochette B de vos documents et
vous verrez mais on a et et je je me
permets de finir et euh on a des projets
là différents face- à face euh parce
qu'on on s'oppose au sein au sein du
conseil général et je l'espère
prochainement au Conseil conseil
départemental on a des projets bien
différenciés bien différenciés et et le
29 mars prochain et bien euh c'est-àdire
bah par exemple on n'est pas d'accord
sur le les moyens qu'on a mis en œuvre
sur la fraude sociale et sur la lutte
qu'on a mis en place la frude ça c'est
ça c'est late à la crème on poursuit on
va posture local que vous qui ne sont
pas dénoncé au niveau national absent ça
on peut pas dire l'inverse nous partons
pour Lyon pour que tous les départements
soi représentés direction Lyon avec le
député UMP de Lyonne Guillaume larivé
qui nous attend bonsoir Guillaume larivé
vous êtes en direct d'osser l'UMP qui
fait face à un Front national fort dans
ce département de Lyonne
aujourd'hui le prier prier message des
Français en général et des habitants de
Lyonne en particulier aujourd'hui c'est
un message d'exaspération un message de
colère contre le gouvernement socialiste
faut bien voir que depuis 3 ans le Parti
socialiste a abîmé la France a affaibli
les Français et ce qu'on voulu dire
aujourd'hui les Français en général et
les habitants de Lyonne en particulier
c'est d'abord cela un carton rouge au
Parti socialiste première remarque
deuxième remarque l'umpu di la droite
arrive en tête lorsqu'elle est tunie et
moi ce soir très simplement je veux
lancer un appel je lance un appel à tous
les habitants de Lyonne si vous voulez
dire stop au Parti socialiste si vous
voulez préparer de vrais changements et
bien il faut se rassembler massivement
dimanche prochain derrière les candidat
umpudi les candidats de la droite
question de Lian met bonsoir Guillaume
l'arrivé bonsoir euh on sait que dans
Lyonne il y a eu un certain nombre de
cantons avec des candidats de l'UMP des
candidats de l'UDI que ça a parfois
euh empêcher certains d'accéder au
2uxème tour quelle est votre position à
vous est-ce qu'il faut soutenir les
candidats de droite les mieux placés
vous soutenez André Villier le président
du conseil général et les candidats qu'
a qu' l' a soutenu quelle est votre
position
là-dessus al ma position elle est
extrêmement simple je suis député de
droite uni allié avec le centre droit
pour lutter contre le Parti socialiste
et ce que je constate c'est très simple
lorsque la droite est unie elle gagne
j'en fait la démonstration dans la
plupart des cantons de liyonne y compris
d'ailleurs dans notre ville d'osser ici
où le maire socialiste desar enregistre
un échec très important pour lui puisque
ses adjoints les adjoints au ma
socialiste sont en très mauvaise
position au second tour quand ils ne
sont pas d'ailleurs éliminés dès le
premier tour lorsque la droite part au
combat uni lorsqu'elle incarne une
volonté un renouveau une envie de de
travailler une envie de bosser
pardonnez-moi cette expression féinaire
de bosser oui je le dis au service de
nos concitoyens et ben on gagne c'est la
leçon de ce premier tour et moi
j'appelle encore une fois les habitants
de Lyonne à amplifier ce mouvement vous
avez nous avons la possibilité dimanche
prochain d'envoyer un message très fort
à François Hollande à Manuel Vals à
Christian tobira stop au Parti
socialiste préparons le retour de la
droite unie au pouvoir merci Guillaume
l'arrivé en duplexe depuis auosser pour
votre réaction merci d'être avec nous
sur France 3 Bourgogne nous allons
partir pour ne où Christophe gaillard
candidat du Front national nous rejoint
avec un gros score du Front national qui
arrive en tête dans votre canton
Christophe gaillard
bonsoir bonsoir donc gros score de votre
parti dans le canton dans votre canton
oui un beau score puisque nous nous
arrivons en tête et devant le Parti
socialiste c'est un canton emblématique
puisque c'était le canton de de pierre
berovvois et de l'ancien président du
Conseil Général de la Nièvre Marcel
charmand donc c'est avec une une grande
satisfaction que je reçois ces ces
résultats à l'instant et en même temps
le deuxième tour risque d'être très très
difficile pour vous qu'est-ce que vous
dites aux électeurs bah qui ont voté par
exemple pour Monsieur benchmark
qu'est-ce que vous leur dites pour qu'il
viennent voter pour vous ce soir bon
écoute je crois que les la majorité des
électeurs a conscience qu'il y a un
certain nombre de problèmes et je crois
qu'ils vont se se décider finalement en
conscience et moi j'ai pas de de de
particularisme à dire aux électeurs de
gauche ou de droite j'ai pas de de de
d'information précise à leur dire
simplement leur dire écoutez le Front
national vous vous l'avez élu à neuverre
je suis le le représentant du Front
national à neure je suis élu au conseil
municipal les les habitants de neuver et
au-delà voi mon travail au quotidien et
puis il y a une réelle différence un
vrai clivage entre le Parti socialiste
évidemment et le et le Front National et
c'est ce que les gens veulent
aujourd'hui on dit que les gens ne
s'intéressent plus à la politique je
crois que aimer moins c'est quand même
aimer encore un peu la politique merci
Christophe gaillard candidat donc sur le
canton de ne 2 merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct de ne on poursuit le
débat peut-être avec on est en train
d'évoquer les différences entre l'UMP le
parti socialiste qui n'était pas
évidente aux yeux de Christian l on peut
le résultat de 6 puisque on a céine
Magli sur notre plateau et qu'on l'avait
pas encore je sais pas les si vous êtes
en mesure de nous le donner alors on
vient de on VI de l'apporter j'ai peu
plus de chance que vous André Gervet et
céine Magli font donc 39,4 % des voix
dans ce canton de Dijon 6 et c'est
Édouard Cavin qui est le patron du Front
national en Côte d'Or et mariejanne
Ligier qui arrive en 2e position avec
29,4 % ce sera donc un duel contre le FN
on a presque envie de dire que ça vous
avantage presque Céline Magli C cette
configuration là alors moi être contre
un parti qui n'est pas républicain non
ça ne m'avantage pas moi je tiens tout
d'abord à remercier les électrices et
les électeurs qui nous ont fait
confiance qui se sont mobilisés et je
les appelle vraiment à se mobiliser le
29 mars parce que nous ne sommes pas
face un parti traditionnel qui voudrait
faire croire qu'il n'est pas d'extrême
droite c'est un parti qui effectivement
est un parti fantôme que nous n'avons
pas du tout vu dans la camp à part
quelques affiches il n'y a eu aucune
présence sur le terrain aucune
proposition concrète on nous parle sans
arrêt de politique nationale mais on est
dans une élection départementale et
cette élection départementale elle
touche la vie des gens elle touche les
personnes handicapées elle touche les
personnes âgé la petite enfance les
collèges les transports la voirie ce
sont des choses concrètes et nous on
propose des choses concrètes
effectivement nous n'avons pas le même
programme que la droite nous pensons
qu'une autre politique départementale
est possible avec au cœur de toutes les
solidarités les valeurs de fraternité
les valeurs républicaines que nous aussi
nous portons et nous pensons
effectivement qu'il est grave d'être
face à un Front National qui est un
parti qui prône des des idées
extrémistes contre lesquelles nous nous
battrons avec détermination avec
ténacité et je peux vous dire que le
courage politique nous l'aurons cette
réforme elle a amené la parité il faut
le rappeler nous étions très 13 % de
femmes dans les conseils généraux nous
serons 50 % demain et je peux vous dire
que c'est avec beaucoup de courage pour
politique que nous affronterons cet
adversaire qui nous semble dangereux
pour notre République vous voulez
répondre Chris lonet je dis ça avant que
vous cédiez la place à François de qui
attend là-bas je vous préviens par
avance ditesnous non mais c'est c'est
tout de même étonnant d'entendre ces
formations politique donner des leçons
de de morale de
démocratie et de et de et de République
ENF votre
bilan au niveau de la Bourgogne est est
catastrophique que faites-vous des
180000 PV par du département oui non
mais le département c'est c'est quatre
c'est quatre départements qui font une
région il y a différ il y a 180000
pauvres en en Bourgogne qui vivent avec
moins de 900 € par mois il y a également
des gens qui travaillent et qui sont
pauvres et avec des enfants pauvres
qu'est-ce que vous pensez faire pour
Monsieur
concrètement att tist dans vos programes
pas interrompu ch madame laiss parler Le
Pen je vous ai pas interrompu chère
Madame euh il y a également 130000
chômeurs maintenant une une une
croissance continue du chômage depuis
depuis maintenant 30 ans et le chômage
outre le fléo économique c'est c'est une
véritable indignité personnelle alors
vous pouvez toujours parler de de
solidarité et de fraternité il faudrait
d'abord commencer par donner de l'emploi
euh vous a parlé des compétences du
département surtout je pense que vous
les connaissez mal connais bien bien
entendu faire c'est agréable pingong
très agréable Lud crochette on a posé la
question tout à l'heure à Alain sugn sur
ces situations B comme dans dans un
canton comme celui-là où la droite est
éliminée que faut-il faire Alain SuG
n'était pas favorable au Nini il est pas
favorable non plus à un appel à votre
républicain quelle est la meilleure
solution finalement pour vous il est
vrai que pour reprendre la position d'
SuG que chaque territoire a quand même
sa spécificité euh mais on ne peut pas
non plus euh enfin on ne peut pas
laisser les clés d'un département à une
formation euh qui qui qui n'aura pas les
moyens de de de de gérer la collectivité
euh néanmoins je le répète on a entendu
la la colère des habitants sur le sur
sur la fiscalité sur sur le les
inquiétudes vis-à-vis de l'avenir et le
Conseil général c'est justement cette
collectivité qui doit répondre à à ses
attentes qui doit répondre au aux
inquiétudes des parents pour le travail
de leurs enfants ou des parents pour la
les maisons de retraite pour leur
propres parents aussi on on est sur
cette collectivité qui est
intergénérationnelle et on ne peut pas
se permettre d'avoir un débat comme on
l'a eu tout de suite sur des notions qui
sont uniquement nationales il y a des
spécificités aujourd'hui nationales une
colère contre la politique gouvernement
gouvernementale et je la partage mais on
est sur des compétences local il faut
que notre réponse soit locale moi de
demain ben je repars en campagne avec
énergie et puis avec beaucoup d'envie
sur le local et sur les compétences du
Conseil Général 10h mois le quart on va
donner la parole à tous les partis le
Front de gauche avec Isabelle de alméda
elle nous attend en direct de la
préfecture de CODOR à Dijon bonsoir
Isabelle de alméda euh vous êtes
candidate sur le canton de chenauvre euh
première réaction d'abord sur ces
résultats en
général sur les résultats en générals
ben malgré euh une abstention qui était
moindre que celle qui était attendue moi
je pense que la crise politique est
encore est encore là puisqu'il y a quand
même une grande partie de nos
concitoyens qui sont pas déplacés donc
il y a une défiance il y a beaucoup
d'indignation et de colère parmi les
gens moi que j'ai rencontré dans la
campagne donc je pense que les résultats
qui sont qui sont que nous avons ce soir
sont pas des résultats qui qui
représentent l'espoir et et qui puisse
porter une alternative pour le moment à
gauche dans le pays question
de est- que c'était une bonne stratégie
finalement dans de mettre des candidats
partout face aux forces de gauche quand
on voit finalement la la relative
faiblesse de de de vos scores à
l'exception de saint-valler en
sonnéloire où là le le Front de Gauche
est en tête
saavalier varen vzel aussi et dans le
pays il y a des des cantons même en côe
d'or où où le le Front de gauche le
Front de Gauche a a a permis à des
électeurs de se déplacer et d'affirmer
des propositions si bien cell de
protéger les politiques publiques des
départements parce que je crois que
c'était ça l'enjeu mais aussi de créer
une alternative à gauche une alternative
aussi à la politique du gouvernement et
en même temps de contrer euh la la
droite et l'extrême droite donc la
question était pas de de présenter euh
nous-mêmes nous sommes je suis une
candidate de gauche donc je me
présentais pas contre les forces de
gauche puisque je suis une candidate
d'une des forces d'un rassemblement de
la gauche on peut voir dans tout le pays
quand même des rassemblements un peu
différents et donc pour le 2ème tour il
y aura une consigne cl
la notre volonté nous c'est de créer un
espoir à gauche une alternative à la
politique gouvernementale et à celle de
la droite et de l'extrême droite donc ce
n'est pas en étant c'est pas en
favorisant la droite et l'extrême droite
qu'on pourra recréer de l'espoir donc
notre consigne ou c'est évidemment le
rassemblement de tous les électeurs de
gauche pour battre la droite et
l'extrême droite merci beaucoup Isabelle
de alméda et vous parlez de l'extrême
droite justement le score du Front
national était à suivre de près sur le
canton de braset en pleine puisque'x
européennes le parti était arrivé en
tête dans 37 des 38 communes du canton
le FN présent au 2è tour face à la
majorité départementale vous voyez
l'escore dans ce canton de Brazet en
pleine ambiance à la salle des fêtes de
Brazet tout à l'heure avec Anne berger
et
tier c'était la fête aujourd'hui à brasé
en pleine mais pas pour tout le monde
dès le dépouillement des premiers
bulletins la tendance se dessine co de
LEP Bernier
Quentin Bernier Quentin et quand les
résultats des communes arrivent c'est le
candidat du Front national qui a le
sourire à côté du secrétaire
départemental du FN sur le terrain on a
des très bons retours ça s'est très bien
passé une bonne campagne on a faire à
des des personnes qui ont un bilan ça
peut être positif ou très négatif et
nous qui amenons des choses nouvelles
comme en 2004 et en 2011 dans l'ancien
canton de Saint-Jean de launne une
qualification pour le deè tour ce
profile pour le candidat FN face cette
fois à la conseillère générale sortante
de sœurs Emmanuel coin pas surprise du
scénario effectivement c'est le scénario
que j'avais imaginer il y avait eu quand
même des élections même si elles étaient
européennes donc peut-être plus
éloignées de nos concitoyens on sait
jamais quelle part va prendre je dirais
la notoriété locale pour autant ça
semblait quand même s'inscrire dans le
dans le périmètre du territoire à
bientôt 20h la candidate socialiste
Chantal Bouvret attend son colistier
Alain bequet le maire de S
elle veut connaître tous les résultats
pour s'exprimer mais dans les rangs de
la gauche on
s'inquiète voilà pour le coton de brzet
en pleine en Côte d'Or François deille
nous a rejoint bonsoir bonsoir pour le
modem question
éico peut-être sur sur les résultats
généraux on voit que le FN est largement
en tête notamment dans Lyonne dans
beaucoup beaucoup de cantons est-ce que
finalement les partis politiques dont le
vôtre vous n'êtes pas en en parti
responsable en disant bah il faut pas
stigmatiser les électeurs donc
finalement les électeurs se disent oh
bah c'est pas grave de voter Front
national ils vont voter Front national
est-ce queil y a pas une part de votre
responsabilité je pense pas que vous
puissiez m'accuser d'avoir dit une seule
fois de voter Front national je dis pas
vous je dis les partis politiqu partis
politiqu s'il y a un parti qui s'oppose
justement je comprends bien les Français
umpps on en a assez on veut le
changement l'alternance même si ça vote
umpps il y a un bastion c'est sûr mais
quand on prendle l'abstention il y en a
beaucoup qui ne veulent plus de ça
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils votent fen pas
de programme on l' vu départemental il y
a pas de programme quand vous regardez
c'est la photo des candidats et le
Verseau c'est c'est la lettre de Marine
Le Pen quand vous interrogez les gens
vous allez voter je le vois dans mes
patients vous allez voter Marine Le Pen
mais le candidat de Marine Le Pen c'est
quoi le programme économique on sait pas
vous savez que c'est un programme
d'extrême gauche ah bon vous savez que
c'est un programme sociéal d'extrême
droite un programme économique de
l'extrême gauche les gens ne le savent
pas ça je veux dire il y a un moment il
faut vraiment et ça je l'ai fait on n
pas arrêté sur le terrain de le dire de
combattre cela de proposer une nouvelle
alternative je veux dire bon on nous
promettait 02 05 1 % alors au niveau
national on donne les chiffres mais ça
veut rien dire parce queon est quand on
est présente dans peu de canton regardez
les cantons de côe d'or on disait Dijon
6 on va faire 1 % le PS et l'UMP c'est
manière un peu au d'ailleurs c'est
parfois c'est 5 pardon Dijon 5 Dijon 5
c'était 1 ou 2 % mon
candidat mon candidat fait 6 et5 % c'est
pour ça que j'étais déjà dans le le
score on fait tout 5 % à peu près
partout et plus 5 % et il y a même un
score je pense à Isabelle losmillard sur
saintapolinaire on ne sait pas encore
les résultatsfinitif mais elle était à
24 24 et5i % il y a quelques minutes je
ne sais pas si ça va lui permettre de
rester au deè on vous pose une question
tout de suite François deille c déjà
nous combattrons le partout où on peut
le combattre le canton de Dijon 5 votre
binôme fait 6,55
% deè tour certes qu son sont vos
consignes de vote en sachant que vous
êtes vous-même élu à Dijon avec le Parti
socialiste au consig je suis élu avec
départ François repsamet dans l'Inter
général des digjeunés C et là nous
allons voir ce qui va se passer avec
Marien louviki Isabelle et puis Cécile
chevalier et nous discuterons de cela en
tout cas donc donc on doit comprendre
qu'il y a pas de consigne de vote
automatique forcément en faveur du Parti
socialiste euh dans certains cantons ça
sera peut-être je peux pas dire ce qui
va se passer dans le sud de la France
parler de Dijon sur Dijon
modem é rangé avec le PS est terminé que
le MoDem se redéplace vers la droite
j'ai jamais dit ça non mais c'est une
question que je vous pose je n'ai jamais
dit ça j'ai dit simplement que nous nous
considérons que les alliances do pas se
faire d'un côté ou de l'autre qu'il y a
des gens les Français en ont assez de
cela d'ailleurs la preuve il ils
s'abstiennent ou ils votent et fen avec
des scores qui sont
honteux voilà donc faudrait peut-être
éviter de donner raison à des grands
sportifs du PSG qui ont dit des choses
néfastes sur la France j'aimerais que
les Français se ressaisissent parce que
voter Front national c'est une catastrhe
donc on n jamais dit qu'on ne voterait
pas avec l'un ou avec l'autre mais c'est
dans l'intérêt général qu'il faut
arrêter de stigmatiser j'entender je
combats j'aime bien Ludovique Rochette
mais on doit pas combattre le PS on doit
travailler avec eux parfois on doit
pouvoir travailler avec d'autres il y a
des gens compétents des deux côtés
travaillons ensemble et offerons une
autre offre politique que toujours
combattre un clan contre un autre qui
nous amemène dans le mur voilà noté pour
cette invitation à l'Union voyons si
elle a réussi à droite selon François sa
réaction attendue depuis la préfecture
de COD d'or bonsoir François Sauvadet
cette union de la droite donc a
fonctionné selon vous pour ces élections
départemental ah oui absolument côe d'or
elle a bien fonctionné d'ailleurs
partout il y a eu des dissidences vous
voyez que c'est l'union qui l'a emporté
et donc c'est d'abord cette force de
l'Union qui a permis en France d'abord
d'adresser un signal très fort mais
aussi particulièrement en code d'or
d'ailleurs vous avez vu que la gauche
est éliminée P dans pratiquement un
tiers des nouveaux cantons qu'elle avait
contribué à à redessiner et à charcuter
et là elle est notamment éliminé dans
votre propre canton hein mais vous êtes
en ballotage très favorable face à un
candidat FN François Sauvadet c'est une
situation à laquelle vous vous attendiez
vous qui avez l'habitude auparavant
d'être élu dans un fauteuil dans votre
ancien canton de
vitau non mais vous savez d'abord
d'abord si les cantons n'avaient pas été
redécoupés vous regarderez le le score
de vitau comme celui de martinéab dans
son propre canton on a assisté à un vrai
charcutage que j'ai eu l'occasion
dénoncer dans de main reprise maintenant
la réalité celle-là mais vous savez on
pressentait que il y all avoir un vrai
CR de colère qu'elle est exprimé par le
peuple d'ailleurs il était exprimé par
beaucoup et sur le terrain moi j'ai
entendu beaucoup de gens qui étaient
mécontents et qui l'ont exprimé dans les
urnes voilà ce cri là il faut l'entendre
maintenant ce que je vais adresser comme
message à l'ensemble des codes de rien
c'est que le deuxième tour sera un tour
décisif et qu'une fois qu'on a exprimé
sa colère y compris en votant pour des
gens du Front national dont d'ailleurs
on ne connaît pas les candidats qui
n'ont même pas de programme puisque même
sur leur programme il ne figurait même
pas le nom code d'or c'est un programme
national donc maintenant que c'est le
tour décisif moi j'appelle chacun à un
esprit de responsabilité de mobilisation
je ne souhaite pas personnellement qu'il
y ait de conseillers départementaux du
Front national en code d'or et ça dépend
pas que de nous ça dépend naturellement
et surtout des électeurs qui sont
appelés aujourd'hui à se proncer et à se
prononcer clairement et à sanctionner
aussi clairement ceux qui doivent l'être
c'est-à-dire ceux qui sont responsables
de cette situation alors j'entends bien
ce qui nous renvoie dos às la gauche et
la droite c'est pas ça le sujet
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
situation dramatique pour beaucoup de
personnes et donc la sanction doit
s'exprimer à l'égard d'un Parti
socialiste qui a tripatouillé un scrutin
et qui d'ailleurs on ne sait même pas
les compétences toujours que devont
assumer les conseils départementaux
c'est vous dire c'est vous dire donc il
faut que cette sanction soit clairement
exprimée au second tour c'est le travail
de mobilisation qu'on va faire de notre
électorat compris vous appelez quand
même à faire battre le Front National et
vous préférez une victoire d'un candidat
socialiste que celle d'un candidat Front
national c'est bien ce que j'ai compris
non attendez vous me ferez pas non non
le combat moi je le mène contre la
gauche vous avez bien compris je suis à
la tête d'une majorité que je veux voir
reconduite au conseil départemental de
la Côte d'Or et donc mon combat il est
clairement d'abord contre la gauche
parce qu'on le voit bien le Front
national n'est pas en situation de
gagner ici en code d'or naturellement la
majorité donc le combat il est
clairement contre la gauche donc je vais
pas lancer d'appel à à l'égard de ceux
que je combats matin midi et soir et qui
mon
les limites de l'exercice y compris en
code d'or n on cessé de fustiger un
certain nombre d'engagements que nous
avions pour les territoires ruraux
d'ailleurs j'aimerais qu'il s'en
explique davantage sur leur choix devant
les électeurs non il s'agit pas de ça il
s'agit simplement de dire que je ne
souhaite pas personnellement je le redis
qu'il y ait un conseil départemental
demain du Front national voilà c'est
assez simple donc c'est chaque électeur
qui devra se prononcer à son âme et
conscience et j'appelle tous ceux qui
sont pas venus voter à se mobiliser
s'ils veulent que de demain il y a un
grand projet un vrai projet porté par
une solide majorité unie pour l'avenir
de la côte d' parce que c'est de ça dont
il s'agit je rappelle un geste de un
geste de mécontentement pendant une
minute ça va nous engager pendant 6 ans
donc c'est un appel à la mobilisation et
à la responsabilisation aussi des
électeurs passer ce moment de Grun que
je comprends et que je partage parce que
j'étais moi-même en colère par rapport à
certaines décisions du gouvernement
c'est dit merci François sovad depuis la
préfecture de CODOR j'entendais cine
maglic bouillonner en entendant fr Saad
oui je bouillonne parce que je crois
qu'à un moment donné il faut être clair
et responsable que j'entends on a des
projets politiques différents il faut
les porter mais il faut être clair dans
cette élection et il faut clairement
j'aurais aimé vraiment que François
Sauvadet dise clairement que la droite
allit appeler à voter pour les candidats
de gauche quand ils étaient face au
Front national comme moi par exemple
avec à voter François qui est pourtant
très très dur avec la gauche non mais il
est très dur avec la gauche comme je
suis très dur avec lui effec
effectivement nous avons des projets
politiques différents nous ne menons pas
effectivement la chasse au fraudeur qui
je le
répète concerne 0,5 % des allocataires
du du RSA en Côte d'Or nous nous avons
un projet politique qui est fondé sur
les solidarités parce que c'est le cœur
de métier d'un conseil départemental
c'est l'action sociale donc moi
j'appelle à la mobilisation des
électeurs le 29 mars et j'espère
qu'effectivement on saura se recentrer
sur les compétences départementales et
ne plus par parler de charcut parce que
moi j'ai un canton je suis élu sur un
canton qui est mixte urbain et rural et
je le défendrai demain pour cette partie
là merci Céline maglic vous restez avec
nous sur France 3 la soirée continue
bien évidemment avec Carole guessler et
Francis leellier dans un instant pour la
synthèse national retrouvons-nous dans
un quart d'heure pour faire le tour
d'horizon des résultats au plus près de
chez vous en Bourgogne à tout à
[Musique]
l'heure